Our session today is on faith and globalization
and human rights, and %uh we have %uh today
with us
up against this
Joan Lockwood and
cool describes himself as a political theologian
you can ask her may be too terribly bit more
about by the political theologian
doug's and hopefully political theologian
might be described a to be
but certainly political theology
he's engaged into using out political implications
well some of the major theological theological
concepts
and she has as you and all written quite extensively
all on human rights they in particular about
the merchants of the human up human rights
in its history
well Ben chavis thought that oxford university
together her husband
%uh also a of moral the laws of that won't
be looking for
and this presents a teaching
at university of denver
I will make a few comments and did not rule
see the flowers to this about
now of
ever since %uh nineteen forty eight
%um
language of human rights
this
increasingly spread around the globe and some
folks even think that's
%um
human rights language is the new
moral code
some have even suggested that it is
a new religion
and the already CNN that phrase
a kind of competition between old-style a
new style
religions that some accounts that these the
rightful religion
and %uh can suggest %uh
but at the same time of the meaning of human
rights is deeply contest that probably is
the the contested as %uh as ever
of some rights that for affirmative by united
nations in nineteen forty eight
would likely bill
the a firm by the same all the up to date
example right to choose months
or change of the in particular change one's
religion
difficult to pass that
%uh now all indeed some scholars believe that
%uh
word given to vote %uh today declaration of
human rights
would not
%um
to be adopted
so what's going on
%um
on the one hand popularity immense popularity
of Wright's language of the other
increase up
clint the station all of human rights and
meaningful human rights
is it possible for human rights to serve as
such as a new global of the global moral column
well even if it were possible would be desirable
human rights the serbs has stopped in some
of the articles that the breadth of of this
violence
but also to a certain degree also Charles
taylor's of
question that is %uh
right of do we need to look for something
like an alternative of to human rights
and %uh and taylor's case it is almost human
rights express the all particular norms and
it's these norms
actually the by ending
globally and are human rights our particular
hirsch investor version
of expressing some
globally binding
norms
of rights to live from maybe with the express
things
but commitment that nobody should not to kill
maybe the more on that
right to live
he is a particular way off of off express
so at any rate there is a sense of both of
the importance of the of the questions friend
of human rights up the language
at the same time
questions about %uh understandings proper
understandings and agreements of those and
even
of the possibility
all agreements on human rights rather than
on something like norms
um-hmm
human rights
it's been great Serbian to be universal
rights
um
%um
this is one phrase rights road
human rights but it might have and it does
have
%uh radical different often radically different
meanings example
%uh and you can see I think some of that even
in that
tax
for this week I believe
of freedom of religion already indicated that
%um
you know universal declaration of human rights
speaks explicitly
all the rights of change
once religious
ummm belong maybe it would be brace the idea
of the freedom of religion rights
read that size religion
but would strenuously
contests the idea
that includes the rights to change one's of
religion
%uh different folks may give give different
press
preferences two different sets of
our rights and
Michael fay all the
cold war discussions
about of human rights where
of societies and the west's time that to favor
negative riots
which the states are obliged to respect from
divisive vote of civil rights political rights
freedom of expression for instance
whereas eastern %uh
folks in the east
to which my you
country that no longer exists the long to
yugoslavia
and besides very much
a positive rights
which is sustained which states was supposed
to guarantee social cultural economic rights
like the rights to open woman write off of
occasions
and you got similar kinds of may be differences
in the of the fetus lawn and %uh west %uh
today if you take the tax that the bread
for today Patrick ramadan
you'll see that most of the rights that the
affirms the long to
those kinds of political ads described here
is a positive a positive rights
%um
%uh whereas %uh
it's rough in the on Wright's highly prized
the in the in the west
and this may be also an indication
all thought
very different conception
right stan
and to quote %uh
promote the love of attacks of western conception
of subjective rights maybe proprietary rights
over he is their spiritual or corporal cup
capabilities than that
that may be one version more amenable right
to the negative
definition of rights
or it may signal something like entire crime
abounds that case the entitlements
%um
Bob kind of moral obligation that certain
other people have
in order to provided
these benefits as far as it is possible rights
since the funds like rights to soledad a lot
of the two of you
%um
understand this is a as the right strictest
be right
so it's important to keep in mind
that
but we mean been invoked human rights in debates
across cultures
and %uh religions
also but I think I want to draw your attention
to
and now but now it's kind of a mantra already
that the diet that just about all every time
the book and that's the celts social relations
and the good
right and you can see it's in understanding
of human rights
call alternative ways of understanding what
the self is what social relations are the
vote
it is
how these are expressed in about a month article
you have it's tracing the the whole development
basically a lining up with the accounts of
the self social relations and the go to the
ds political a as well as the economic arrangements
of centered around
the notion off human of human rights
%um hum
you concede
similar thing being to of
but expressed again and of freedom of religion
um
freedom of exercise
the footage in
predominately have been mostly communities
but also Jewish and it is
until very recently I think the catholic tradition
%uh as well
um
itself is already the bloc defined by social
relations here a path to make it through your
muslim right
that communities have a state himself being
part of that metaphorical these relationships
this particular social relations
freedom of choice
I think self here stands much more on its
own
who is in the act all
choosing
aligning itself we it's %uh with with others
and the longing to a particular community
I think both are discussing leads of no obviously
not
%uh was very interested in in in this is a
right you've got the conception their itself
right to a in her case of what it means to
be a female of self
which was very much included
it almost like a close-knit account
wolf the world rights of men are alumna and
women alike moon and the and the and the sun
the sting roles this from natural ways in
which we have men and women behave
of community in this particular case a family
is being highly prized
and because of that
you can put a lawyer own
behavior of this book itself
%uh and have your own
quote unquote rights in the context of all
define the context of the community
it's very much different than what
the of most a few have expressed in this discussion
which is I think the reflect that
they're much of western
understanding all of rights which is drives
the fine precisely against the kinds of communities
both which she
describe herself as the logging so that if
anybody wants to
the VA it's quote unquote from that
the able to do that and %uh there
quote unquote going the other way
would be you
precisely this but then again
a very different understanding of
we'll sell is
what the social relations are
and what the court
yes
let me make a few comments also there briefly
about
religion
and writes in particular
and then i'll just %uh in like this with on
the moon to of to speak to us
one might understand the relationship between
religion and rights even if you
the braves rights defines subjective rights
use to describe in as
competing moral universe
text which we haven't read appear at lost
on
I will follow
text on human rights for mostly perspective
he says well of there's a tension between
commit conviction will system of religion
and of human rights
and the question is which of these to generalized
an object to fight systems
warrants deference
and which constitutes
the ultimate frame of reference
which one from swiss which this is a very
important of discussion
it's important discussion in the whole context
of globalization
and worries think social social status is
%um
the you can understand that nobody there is
complete the competing reform
possibilities to understand them
as supporting that that moral planes
this has been generally the tradition in recent
years of the conflict %uh doctor right
you got the call of the states ultimate in
general norms
in human rights reflection articulates
specific norms
to be subordinate said
to general
why
and generally people the group
boss religious convictions the that the braves
let me turn rights
this is the roughly holiday
have formulated this it being the case I think
that for most religious people
the religious world views are the overarching
ones that everything else that's different
subordinate that itself of to to that
number
and there's some folks who think that there
are these are
competing but complete answer
%um
what about pounds off
no arms
they have in perfectly overlapping basis of
support in our culture
and both can be
partly that competitive of partly they are
overlapping
not one more to your comments about of me
religion and human rights
%um
the question that of up
sometimes is being
raise
these blood
it is
that insufficiently
justified
respect for human rights
and even apart from justification
all human rights
what can walk today
people actually two
respect rights rather than
quite simply
for their own rights
Bob
take along the respect of human rights
as
a moral
calls respect
and struggle for rights off up of of it
there are folks will argue %uh
so if you'll of might be the what will not
be surprised though that the up in this plot
in this plot
that actually
the only
do you think
the grounding of human rights
this fall so
that is to say that you can't
you can on okay for human rights but you can't
sufficient justification
for those rights
%uh apart from some kind of but the stick
he is the topic is that right
some kind of a the stick
and generally the argument goes
something like that I like this and what do
you think ground rights inhuman the prostitutes
but there are all sorts of folks
who's at fault of the range
of those capacities
that's you have specified is grounding human
rights something like Russian arctic
well they're all sorts of folks school
you don't quite know aren't quite get there
war
be in the
the bear dance sufficient %uh significant
ways
and I are generally two nations tells us that
we ought to ascribe rights
if this progress and about
anybody also
and there's no way in which you can all throughout
the way in which you can
ascribe rights right in there for legitimize
right
%uh except through some form of capacity some
functions market
%uh and then that's what you have it
and so on nichols' what's in store for very
nice book on it
very much up the light
and it's called we've just of who want nice
the grieving
I recommend that that book about four hundred
pages of fifty %uh
he argues
that the only way we did you can justified
human rights is by appeal
to some kind of relationship between human
beings
and of the plug on and human beings in this
case
he basically says of 'em
got
has affection
for human beings
he likes that
and things that you like
you invest the rights their investments in
the things that you like and that gramm grounds
human rights abuses and police this'll
teddy bear all Bob
the trial
the recall much on has been so much so much
time and
if you were to feel up
the study their in the contest for the beauty
at of teddy bears %uh the may it get the las
plays of right
but if you lost the kid
which teddy bears his or her favorite it's
the one with whom with here she has left
over the many have many months and many many
years
it doesn't matter what capacity the teddy
bear that's right
what matters is the talks with the bucket
so the that to the tune of that something
similar of and walters argues
is the case in relationship between gone
and human beings quite apart from kind of
capacity is one has is the attachment investment
in this case the ballot in human beings that
grounds
they're human of human rights their intrinsic
a intrinsic worth and also
of human courts
%um
let me stop up here and house on
but to me
this about